i'm in bengaluru to visit sun mobility
which is one of india's largest
producers of swappable batteries and
swap stations
when it comes to battery shopping it
hardly takes two minutes to swap
set of three batteries for an auto
rickshaw
and lesser than a minute to swap one
battery for a two-wheeler
so it is as good as going to a fuel pump
and refueling within a couple of minutes
in india we are seeing a very high level
of adoption in applications such as
auto rickshaws which are used for large
mile transport the whole uh reminds of
large smile delivery is how long you can
keep the vehicle on the road delivering
goods right the more deliveries the
vehicle does the more is earning
battery swapping in india is a better
fit for commercial operations that
demand short and quick trips to be made
throughout the day rather than personal
use
companies like amazon big basket that
are in the business of delivering food
groceries
and any form of cargo
use battery swapping to power their
electric scooters and rickshaws
battery swapping makes sense for india's
crowded cities
where finding land to park millions of
vehicles for charging will be difficult
india's battery swapping market has many
hurdles to overcome
some drivers say they're traveling
shorter distances per charge with
battery swapping compared to when they
used to conventionally charge their
electric vehicles
others pointed out that these batteries
can be too heavy to lift
and for companies setting up an
automated battery swap station can be
more expensive than building a fast
charging station
it will be interesting to see if india
takes to battery swapping considering
the technology did not gain widespread
acceptance outside of china and even
tesla abandoned battery swapping due to
poor uptake
[Music]